[Music]
hello so first of all I wanted to
apologize for the poly Apple I who would
have thought something like that would
really Christian but anyways seriously I
mean take one for the road
there there and we don't want to waste
them yeah of course yeah yes I'm
struggling with yeah just a second oh
great okay so we're back okay great yeah
so my name is Richard Bruce Lee I work
at yaara o yaara it's a chemical company
fertilizer they produce fertilizer since
over a hundred years so they're
definitely not a startup they also have
a lot of like sites which do R&D and do
a lot of experiments with the plants
unless Marko already explained in his
talk that is kind of a difficult thing
to do because in all of the different
areas of the world plants behave
differently and then there is change
from one crop to another and so on and
recently Yarra has ventured out into the
digital branch and is trying to pull all
this knowledge that the agronomists over
in this company have acquired over the
last 20 years or so to pull this into
digital products and I'll give you a
short overview over that after a
motivation it's actually I mean the
problem is that food will be a huge
problem in the future if you look at
this graph and we see that in 1960 they
were all in like 3 billion people in the
world and now we are over more than
double of that
and in the near future it will increase
even further drastically what happens
after that is still not really sure but
the trend is just going up if we haven't
have a look at how we actually use all
this habitable land that we have on this
earth there is no more than that we
already use 50% of that just for
agriculture and if we want to feed more
and more people we either could chop
down the rest of the forest there is
that's actually going on at the moment
we could plant in the desert but that's
what the current political situation are
very likely so we probably have to make
a much more efficient use of how we
doing things currently I wanted to show
you like one picture which I find very
shocking so this is like the south of
Africa America and sorry from space you
can see the contours here and you might
also spot the the jpg artifact so to say
directly over the Google thing and at
the top over there these are actually
not artifact but if you do zoom in
you'll see that these are gigantic
fields which have just been chopped into
the forest and just look at the scale
down below it's 50 kilometers I mean 50
kilometers for one field even more
that's really a problem and if this
keeps going in the next 20-30 years we
don't have any forests left and we run
into a lot of different problems and
also waste lot of resources so the thing
is how to grow the food more sustainable
and make do with what we are actually
currently using and to this end Yara is
now undergoing a digital transformation
which is not an easy task in an already
established company which is very
traditional and they created several
hubs around the world one of them in
Berlin that's where I work
and they already now delivered several
products one of them is at farm that is
using satellite image analysis to
suggest to the farmer a certain
variation of how to give the fertilizer
within one field so if you just look at
the right under the generate application
map there is like this one field and you
see some bold areas and some some very
green areas and you want to vary the
amount of fertilizer that is spread out
by the tractor on the go and this app is
doing this in a way that you can as a
farmer download the application map
uploaded on the tractor tractors
nowadays are pretty far advanced in
general farmers as they leading huge
businesses oftentimes they are very much
at the cutting edge of agro tech so the
tractor can understand this while
driving and GPS monitoring it can
actually just very on-the-spot the
amount of fertilizer that is added
that's the same with pest control and so
on and this product is actually already
making a difference even though it has
been released this year we are already
covering like over a 800,000 hectares
with this so that's I mean on a global
scale that is still very small but what
we are we improving that so a similar
product and this is the one I focus on
today is how to irrigate more precisely
and especially very valuable tree crops
if you have it as a farmer invested into
a large orchard and has Platt have
planted these trees first of all you
have to wait for a certain time
until you can reap any benefits of that
and then you want to do this over
several years and you really don't want
your plants to die so you need to
irrigate these these fields and if
something like for instance in
California the climate is increasingly
harsh and there are increasing amounts
of droughts over the last years the
trend is clear I mean they will
transform into a desert
this makes irrigation very necessary and
so in order to not waste any water and
this actually has come already into the
public and media that there is actually
no more water left anymore and we are
drafting on ground water which is
actually not refilling at the same speed
not even close
so what reservoirs which are below
ground in like solid rock they refill
over the timescale of a thousand years
or so a little bit but we are pulling
out water every year to pour on our
trees and other crops and we are
actually wasting this so to reduce the
amount of water that is needed is
actually very necessary
that's where work and adaptive
irrigation in drought management so the
idea is to combine different factors
like weather data of course I mean when
it's hot you need to water the plants
more than if it's not hot but also like
field configurations also different
irrigation scenarios because sometimes
you want the plants to suffer for
instance olive trees when the fruits are
already like dark and ripe you don't
want to give the trees any water anymore
because we want to have olives which
full of oil and not full of water but
usually you want to keep them at a
certain satisfying level and for this
you need if you want to manage this in
why you need to relate the state of the
plant to some abstract water status
which you can then regulate over time
adaptively so for instance here it would
be optimal to have it somewhere in the
middle to the left we would waste water
to the right we would risk the plant
dying at a certain point and then put
this into the pipeline to then in the
end give some recommendations or even
edit to a certain automatic irrigation
system and of course over yeah this
problem is not new and a lot of
scientists agronomists have already
created ideas and models and rules about
this and they themselves can identify
plants or can identify the water status
for their plants very easily but how can
we translate this into a computer model
and we need to somehow pull the
knowledge out of them to really then
feed this into a certain model and the
first step is to equip these orchards
with sensors which capture different
parameters like the moisture of the soil
the temperature the rainfall but also a
how sturdy the leaves themselves are so
we add some pressure sensors to some of
the leaves on some of the trees and we
can monitor over time whether the leaves
hang down or whether they are really
sturdy and my talk is called using are
in the mid size data scenario so what
does this mean so our data is not big
data it is fairly large data but it
still fits into a sequel database why we
just continuously feed new new readings
over time with with our IOT setup and
then on the other hand why do we use our
well a lot of people in the company in
the agronomic sector
in general they already tend to speak
are to a certain degree there is here
and there somebody of code already
existing to to include this in our
routines at least at the start has
proven very beneficial to the whole team
idea and the progress to them also some
of the agronomists they start with using
our a little bit and then they grow into
their role so you kind of educate those
people in that regard that's actually a
very good thing for this specific
problem at hand
we have tried several different things
also these undefined extra feeds and so
on which is really not a good idea and
in fact we have then settled down to use
a shiny that is a package for our in our
studio which allows for the creation of
rather simple internal web applications
from our so you get all the information
with someone who does interact with it
directly into the our session and so on
which is rather convenient because then
n is everything is in one language and
there the agronomists can add their
comments their marks and labels and
evaluates and we of course take
everything of that out and put it into a
sequel database so we can keep it for
later and build different datasets from
that yeah so we combine this with with
the curated raw data of course and want
to build a model out of this and here I
want to yeah just mention the concept
that Wes brought up this morning the
interoperability with other programming
languages and to that regard our and our
studio as especially has made some very
good progress in the past so there is
the reticulate package which kind of
combines the r and python engines
in a way that at least some of the data
sets can be memory-mapped between them
and you can then easily switch back and
forth between the two I will give you
later as a short example of this it's
actually really easy to use and it also
facilitates transition like an organic
transition from R into Python if you
want to go more into that direction so
this of course opens up caris and
tensorflow and everything like that
and it's very straightforward to just
then take the different models for
different tree crops and so on and
different conditions and just put them
yeah push them into a tensile or we
should which of course then in the end
allows as we still have mid sized
datasets for a nice online serving
environment which still uses the our
intensive flow combination to generate
this artificial water status which then
at later steps can be combined with the
other factors I mentioned to generate
recommendation the question is yeah we
use our so there are a lot of like
packages from party providers and so on
and to really make this they are
environment reproducible and to write
the code in a way that it doesn't behave
subtly different in a different
environment and also to have it portable
and scalable horizontally scalable so we
can just duplicate these environments we
of course use docker for this and there
is a very nice project which already
wraps our together with our studio and
some other packages based on daily
snapshots from the complete our package
archive and then you can just define
which kind of version you want to use
which makes it very easy for the
development process to really define at
what point do you want to make a
transition to a new version of a package
and then you can control just update
this so we can use it in our like
mid-sized data set for both development
and production so you would just specify
your version number there and you can
just use them our studio very
conveniently similar to Jupiter from
your browser which is very convenient
although you need to keep in mind that
like for instance this password is just
an environment variables so everyone who
has root access to the host machine can
read it in clear text and also if you
want to go outside there is no HTTP
coming whether it's so use a proxy for
that yeah and the next step you of
course want to do the same for Python as
well so you want to have our in a
defined version with all of their
packages and you want to use Python with
all of the epoch this package is also in
a defiant version and there is the PI
end project on github which nicely
achieves that and there even is a very
convenient straightforward
implementation of using this and adding
it up on the darker container it's
basically just taking the rocket ID
verse and adding the PI and cloning the
PI and on top so some other things if
you and this is very convenient I
suggest you do this develop all your
packages within this environment you
might you want to persist your data of
course and you want to add a volume in
to this and one thing I struggled once
with it is that the user ID must match
with the host system that is just
something I wanted to mention
yeah you can just follow this link
another thing that came up yesterday
once is the question of how to integrate
Microsoft sequel databases and in the
past this was not so very easy to get it
run with different Linux environments
but nowadays Microsoft is doing really
an effort to get this going and
installing the ODBC drivers for
Microsoft or do pcs yeah it's it's a bit
wordy but it's still doable and you can
just just add this as another taça file
at the end and build this so next
question how do you handle secrets and
for all of the interactive sessions
there are two packages which allow for
asking for a password and a secure
rather secure manner and of course again
if you want to do something non
interactive you could use kubernetes for
handling those secrets this is also very
straightforward now I would like to show
you some short things anecdotes which I
found very useful for my progress one is
that our studio offers if you want to
communicate with other people on the
team especially those which are not
really programmers or data scientists
but more like agronomist sand biologists
you want to supply them very often with
explicit plots and information about
what you're actually doing and you like
running around in circles asking them
yeah like this and then discussing
different ideas are offers a lot of
notebook e style things but I personally
don't found them very useful because you
need to copy the code into different
elements and so on but it's also now
possible to just write some code clean
it up a little press this button and
then it will generate a very nice report
out of that and in this example
I show you the usage of this particular
package so this is in our environment
and you just take a string which
contains some Python code I defined here
a Python function in a very easy one and
in a later call I just from this Python
function from R it just calls the Python
environment with some input parameters
which I took from R as you can see here
below and then in the end the answer is
42 so another thing I found very useful
for when building shiny apps so shiny is
I would say in my experience it's useful
for generating small proof of concept
things which serve as a report so if you
want to make an internal dashboard or
want to visualize something
interactively this is very useful and
also if you want to share like simple
interactivity with someone who's not not
a programmer then debugging this might
be sometimes a little bit not so
straightforward but with this with this
react lock you can you can like visually
represent very easily what actually
takes place in your app which makes it
much easier also sometimes when you have
encountered an error during developing
with this shiny sometimes the logs are
actually not stored because the app
thought that the program completed
without error and in this case adding a
custom Chinese server config to the
docker file helps out in that and also
play around with the init and idle time
or times this can be during development
something which is very useful mmm
that in the end if you want to set up
this as a web service the plumber
package is very easy to use from our
because it just lets you decorate your
code in a similar fashion as oxygen the
documentation package but with a
different handle and then you can just
call it as a web service so this is also
very nice to integrate it into some like
yeah mid sized data volume processes the
focus here is always on like getting the
different elements working together and
the different people working together as
we don't have like big data and need to
efficiently run everything but we want
still to have a quality answer at the
end so for this this whole setup has
proven to be acceptable yes and then now
to come to an end we are using Apache
airflow or starting to using it using it
more and more because it has proven also
to be very facilitative in migrating
small bits of these jobs and requests
yeah and if anyone hasn't hasn't yet
done and done this it's even for smaller
projects very useful to just integrate
it into your workflow yara as a whole is
now starting a new initiative to really
characterize a crop and really simulate
the whole crop like from the seed to
forming the roots and keeping track of
the whole weather conditions and
everything and this is actually starting
so if you want to or if you're
interested in this and so on you should
come
talk to us so this was a rather short
talk but I hope you still found it
somewhat interesting thank you
you